the value of a certain fraction becomes
1/5 if one is added to its numerator he
if one is taken from its denominator its
value becomes 1/7 find the fraction this
is a weird question right okay now the
first thing we need to identify which is
harder here than it was in this question
is we wrote two simultaneous equations
because we had two things to pronumerals
unknowns that we were solving for okay
now there are two unknowns in this as
well this is just not quite as obvious
at least there wasn't when I first
looked at it what two things might I be
trying to find which would help me
create the two equations what two things
are there that their value will help me
get the answer so there's a fifth that
that's a value that's in the question
right but it's not the like that unknown
the thing I'm trying to solve for okay
in what you writing numerator and
denominator if I worked out what those
two were that's the entire fraction
isn't it right so here's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna say let the fraction
be and I'm going to name the numerator
and the denominator as just like I did
before I'm gonna name them as perennials
so that I can subsequently find them
okay we could call them in and day for
numerator and denominator okay
so I've introduced these two letters
what I'm gonna do with them now I'm
gonna use them by writing an equation
right so let's have a look at the first
sentence which gives us an equation
we're gonna translate this okay where do
I go here we go if the fraction becomes
1/5 if 1 is added to its numerator so
here is the original fraction right how
would I write this with 1 added to the
numerator and plus 1 there we go I've
added 1 to the numerator and the
denominator it has not changed ok so
when you do this what's the fraction now
equal to 1/5 very good so here's my
first equation and then you have a look
at the second sentence which gives you
another piece of information from which
you can construct an equation one
equation you're going to construct this
time
yeah very good so the denominator I'm
going to yes subtract one D minus 1 and
that numerator hasn't changed okay
what's that equal to 1 over 7
okay here we go so the first method we
had a look at was elimination right and
it's very very useful when your two
equations they they look so close to
each other they're like really really
subtly different and you can tweak one
in a very minor way so that the one of
the perennials just disappeared okay
this one's a bit more messy right it's
not so straightforward all I can just
multiply or divide by something and then
add or subtract so what was the other
method it starts with it s is in
remember substitution very good so in
order to try this out right substance
you should what I want to do is
rearrange one of these equations so that
the one of the pronumerals whichever one
you like will be the subject of the
equation and then I can substitute that
into the other equation right so we can
go for the letter n or the letter D
which do you think might be easier to go
for that was really interesting I think
I heard like 50/50 on that okay people
who said letter M why am what would you
do which equation would you look at to
muck around with number two this guy
here so you can see the letter n just
appears right there in the front all by
itself right in fact there's only a
single thing you need to do to this
equation right let's rearrange this
together there's only a single thing you
need to do to make n the subject what
would I do to both sides multiply both
sides by D minus one that leaves me with
this okay now remember I said to you
before I liked your name equations if I
muck around with an equation and then
get a new one out yeah say that again
yeah I think I think I know you think
yeah did you spot you out yep so I'm
gonna call this equation two a now the
reason what I call it two ways because I
got it from two let me show you why I
don't write this down let me show you
why it's a bad idea to not know where
equations came from I looked at this
equation I'm like I need to substitute
this this is the name of the strategy
right substitute this into one of these
equations okay hmm which one shall I try
uh
maybe I'll put it into
equation - why not instead of writing it
I'm gonna write D minus 1 on 7:00 right
and then that's divided by D minus 1
that's equal to 1 over 7 apparently okay
let's see what I can do here there's a D
minus 1 on the top and if t minus 1 at
the bottom so I could cancel those right
that's a common factor on the top of the
bottom so if I cancel that cancel that I
get 1 over 7 on 1 equals write a second
well what what just happened
is this right is this is this a true
statement well I mean the last time I
divided a seventh by 1 I did you get a
seventh so and which because I did that
all the time so it seems correct it is
correct it's just useless right how did
this happen well why did this happen
yeah
yeah I rearrange this equation and then
I put it back into itself right which it
shouldn't surprise us doesn't give us
any useful information right so you
can't put an equation back into itself
and expect something useful to emerge
you have to take an equation that's been
rearranged like this and you have to put
it somewhere else
this strategy substitution kind of
requires you to know where the equation
came from and then put it not back into
itself okay has to go somewhere else
okay so that's why I call this two-way
so I know where it came from I'm going
to substitute this to a instead of
putting it back into the original
equation I'm gonna go into a different
equation I can I'm gonna pause now I
reckon you guys could take this from
here okay be careful you're gonna have
some fractions on fractions but we've
been working with algebraic fractions
have a go see if you can find out what
the numerator denominator will be and
then tell us what you come up with yes
I've been really encouraged by how many
of you have arrived at a solution some
of you arrived at the solution in a
different you just took a different
approach altogether which is totally
fine I'd love you to compare what I'm
about to do with what you did and see
which one you prefer in many cases with
algebra it's sort of much of a muchness
just which one is faster which one is
less error-prone okay so here's the
first thing I'm doing I'm just following
up picking up where we left off we have
this 2a we've made n the subject as the
name suggests I can substitute that into
the other equation this is what I get
when I put it into one now I'll admit it
looks a bit gross at the moment because
it has fractions on fractions but that's
not complicated to fix right in this
case because I have a fraction on the
left hand side fraction on the right
hand side I can cross multiply right I
can remind my both sides by 5 which
leaves me with this and there's no
longer a 5 on the right hand side
because it cancels and I'll also
multiply both sides by D which would
cancel the 1 down in this denominator
and it's going to appear on the right
hand side ok now this is better I don't
have fractions on fractions anymore but
I did still have fractions so I need to
deal with those ok in here we want two
common denominator right to put these
two so they play together so
I'd write this instead of one I can
think of it as what to know man I do I
have you so I can write it as seven over
seven right so I'll just I might as well
put that step in seven over seven and
you can see here these these are going
to come to play right
do you take away one plus seven D
careful with the science take away 7
take away one plus 7 is plus six isn't
it right
so D plus six on seven I've got another
fraction here and I don't want it around
right so I've got this equation I might
as well multiply both sides by seven and
that will get rid of all my fractions at
last okay so that leaves me with this
okay so that's where I'm up to
I'm so very close right I'm almost there
I just need to yeah I'm gonna expand
that left-hand side which leaves me with
5d plus 30 thank you
equals seven lots of D I'm going to
collect my like terms now right what am
I going to do both sides what can i
subtract five date from both sides right
that leaves the 30 on its own over here
on the left and it leaves me with two
lots of d the denominator on the right
hand side so now we've determined its
value are you happy with that just see
how it worked do you see how we're
calling on all the knowledge we've been
developing over the last little bit on
algebraic fractions and how important it
is to be fluent in those am I done I'm
not done okay I have another perennial
to work out this is a value where do you
think is the best place to substitute
this into one this one here yeah yeah it
will totally work remember we already
established you can kind of put it in
anywhere I'm going to suggest there's a
better candidate just ever so slightly
better we want to find we've found what
the denominator is I want to find what
in the numerator is there's a place
where I'm just saying the numerator
equals right and that's what I want to
end up with where is it
it's two it's right here right so I
could have used this you'll get the
right answer okay but if I've already
sort of done the work to make in the
subject I might as well use it
right
so I'm going to substitute into 2a and
that gives me this and equals 15 take
away one on seven numerator here is
going to be 14 divided by 7 gives you 2
and of course you could check that out
right if 2 over 15 is the fraction which
by the way it's important that you
actually answer the question the
question says what is the fraction right
what were the two things they suggested
right what happens if I add one to the
numerator what is it's become 3 on 15
does that check out 3 and 15 it is right
that's that's 1/5 and what if I subtract
one from the denominator that'll become
2 on 14 which is indeed one and seven
okay so I'm happy with that
all right yeah it it did right well
you're outsourcing your brain is what
you're doing right like could you do all
of this in your head i I couldn't write
but if I put it on paper I can break it
down into steps that my brain can manage
ok